so Peter you've been using the switch
light for a better part of a week and
you kind of had to take some time to
come around on the switch light overall
what was your testing process like and
what was it that kind of made you come
around on switch light well I just kind
of dove right in
you know it's tiny $200 switch $100
cheaper than the original and at first
the size it was kind of an issue for me
mostly feeling like confident
controlling and playing games but you
know time is the best teacher in this
case and I've learned to love the switch
after playing it casually after playing
it you know in dedicated sessions where
I'm just focused on gaming and yeah it's
a great little device but it does have
its challenges you're someone who likes
hardware I sure do and I don't think
that you've got much of a chance to play
with this yet so I'm here to answer any
and all of your questions okay what do
you know about the switch light what's
your what's your concept
it's a smaller switch is what I'm
thinking when I look at this of course
now that comes with a lot of different
questions so the first thing I want to
ask is about the screen and the size of
things that are represented on the
screen yeah particularly text and maybe
some some of the action that's happening
on screen does that affect your
experience ah not so much there are some
cases so in general this is a 5.5 inch
screen compared to the 6.2 inch screen
on the standard switch I will say
honestly nine times out of 10 things
look a little bit better on the screen
than the original simply because the
reduced size six will tend to be right
yeah higher pixel densities so things
like jaggies on games that don't have
any icing it's not resolved but the
jaggies are diminished a little bit but
one problem though as you asked
regarding text ono is really a thing so
Fire Emblem I'm not yet 35 which I don't
think makes me an old man but maybe I'm
old but you were saying that you - yeah
I was kind of struggling yeah I was
looking at this thing I'm like who was
looking at the local I'm trying to talk
to of course I could see their face in
this thing but reading text is a bigger
part of a lot of games that I play
particularly something like Fire Emblem
where it's Lara
it's very dialogue driven and when you'd
not when you're not given options for
text size that is a problem and I think
about like games on the 3ds naturally
had big text because they know it's a
portable thing and I feel like that
might be a missing piece potentially
I've seen a lot of switch
over the years back when I was using
just the standard model right where I
was like okay clearly they formatted
this text for the TV experience right
and the handheld is sort of treated as
the secondary thing but handheld is the
primary thing with switch light of
course so when you run into things that
are that way for whatever reason you
don't really have any way to justify
that it's okay it actually it feels like
a bit of a downgrade in that regard
hopefully developers will kind of get
the memo maybe a Nintendo will nudge
them and they can start to incorporate
options to help with this but honestly
by and large like being a smaller switch
it was a bit of a challenge for me at
first mostly because of the controls
which as I said in the review I thought
were kind of cramps turns out they're
not they're actually very closely spaced
compared to the original model it's just
that this grip down here you lose
something it's always gonna ask about
the controls in particular because you
know text size and the screen size is is
one thing but you know actually having
it in your hands is yet another thing
and I I don't mind the normal switch I
got I got big hands and all that but I
don't mind the normal switch and the
droid cons I didn't mind the plane on
the 3ds either yeah and I don't see
there being a problem with the switch
light but was that the case in your
experience it's just getting used to the
difference right because I was trained
to use something that was a little bit
bigger took about two days or so before
I realized oh wait a minute I'm not
thinking about the feeling of using
these controls anymore which meant they
feel normal
I'm at the stage now having used it for
the better part of a week where I'm
actually not sure I want to go back to
the larger controls there are other
reasons why I still preferred this
switch over this one yeah it's certainly
something that I've gotten used to and
especially with the proper d-pad now
yeah you know playing something like
Celeste playing something like Street
Fighter with you know really specific
input demands it feels so good just to
have this d-pad and just highlights how
annoying it is to not have it on the
standard switch the reasoning makes
sense obviously they want these
controllers to have parity because they
can you know both be like used as
controllers on their own for two players
that's not the case here shouldn't end
oh said screw it put back the d-pad and
there's a good decision
oh yeah I know Hori has like a a joy
Khan type controller that has a deep
it's not Wireless it doesn't quite fit
as perfectly into the ecosystem as these
do but it also got me thinking like
maybe if there's a new switch that's
more powerful
maybe the droid cons don't have to come
off I don't know about you I don't
usually find myself breaking them off to
give you a second player usually people
are looking forward to the pro
controller right we're like a GameCube
controller or something like that
getting carried away they're just
thinking about the future but yeah it's
just that just highlights how well the
system feels particularly because the
joy cons aren't removable and I'm enjoy
cons at all it's all just one piece this
feels really sturdy mm-hmm I don't find
myself like thinking like oh crap I'm
bending this this way or that I've
handed this to people who are like oh
this makes me realize how magic how
crappy my joy cons are because they are
literally like yeah all the time like
this their creak creaking off the hinges
and stuff I've been using a switch for
very long time like that doesn't
necessarily bother me but I can see a
way in which over the years it might
cause problems but here I mean yeah it's
all one thing so nothing's coming out
and it feels like one unibody piece yeah
it's like subconsciously that makes a
difference oh yeah because I literally
don't think twice about you know when I
play rocket League I do that thing where
I like move even though obviously don't
have any impact on the game because I
get served I get really into it
definitely a loser
particularly the buttons themselves yeah
have they changed in terms of feel not
necessarily the materials feel a little
bit different but the actuation and the
the proper feel of using the buttons
doesn't feel notably different to me at
all okay the triggers on the back on the
top are a little bit smaller but again
that didn't really stick out to me in
any meaningful way now the internal
hardware same as the other switch right
as far as I know yes I know there was a
recent teardown done online I haven't
watched that although I did hear that
they removed deep video encoder which is
used to output through the dock to your
TV so you were asking me before we
started shooting you put it in the dock
maybe tried to connect it to a TV still
got the USB C port right there it's got
that port but you cannot with the
internals as they are connect this to
your television which that is really the
biggest issue with this device and I
hate to think that that one ship is the
difference in cost it can't
there's no way that that accounts for
$100 but it certainly diminishes my
appreciation or my desire for this
device in particular because as you know
having a thing that can be either
handheld or a console that's the point
of the switch that's the reason it's
called what it is name right that's the
thing we got used to like you've seen
devices in the past like PSP for example
start out like this and then Sony will
revise it and then give you the ability
to put them cook it up to your TV
Nintendo went the opposite approach here
it just feels strange the device itself
is really good and and so that's kind of
an issue for me is that I wish in Tendo
had just maybe up the price by 50 bucks
yeah and included that feature maybe you
don't get a dock right you don't really
need a doc you just have a USB C port
like it's a standard thing it's not some
proprietary time this is a dedicated
portable device and you can be taking it
on the go 100% of time so battery life
is much more important yeah this time
around yet for the switch light so how's
that been so again it's going to use
rocket League as an example it's a
really demanding game especially when
playing online with other people like
it's just taking everything out of the
system that it can give I was able to
get just over four hours of gameplay
just like sitting there one day chillin
doing it was only occasional breaks
which is pretty good in my opinion using
the standard switch that I was used to
like I could never get more than like a
couple hours it felt like at best so
that was really good but more of like a
real-world test because I'm not always
sitting down to play switch four hours I
took about three days to treat this as
just a casual thing I'm gonna use right
leave it in standby mode maybe I'll
download a game that I thought of that I
want to play it later maybe it's a small
one or a big one maybe I'll sit down for
half an hour 20 minutes and play a game
I was able to keep that routine up for
about three days before I felt like I
had to recharge it and even then it
wasn't like dead it was like it was like
the second battery warning that's really
good for me as someone who's experienced
constantly turning on their old switch
from standby mode and it's saying
battery dead or whatever it was like you
have to recharge it so all things
considered it's really good the the
rated battery life is less than that of
the improved standard switch model but
you know I'll be honest like I was I was
pretty impressed with what they were
able to get out of this device because
it is smaller which means the battery
itself has to be smaller
okay there are a lot of folks who
primarily play their switch on the go
and held only there's a lot of
conversations about you know should I
got a switch light or not is this for me
and I imagine that that crowd is
probably looking at this thing a lot
harder than maybe other people who
already have a normal switch and docket
occasionally yeah what would you say to
them about the switch light is this up
their alley consider what games you want
to play if you only want to be a single
player gamer at least in terms of like
local you know situations then yeah
maybe this is fine right maybe you'll
play with your friends online but if you
want to get together and play with other
people who maybe don't have joy cons or
pro controllers and you need to supply
them you need to seriously consider why
you're choosing this because if you need
to go that route
and pick up new controllers you're
coming so close to the cost of the full
price switch right which has built-in
controllers has all the features that
this doesn't this also doesn't have like
Rumble at all let alone just HD Rumble
it has none so you know that's sort of
like a secondary thing but really it
comes down to is this a personal device
or is this a device you want to share
with other people that's the biggest
question you need to ask the alternative
is that this could be your second switch
or really your primary switch Nintendo
does allow you to share accounts across
devices your primary device doesn't have
to be online if you want to use that
profile on any secondary devices have to
be online if you want them to access
your library of games and saves it so
you could in theory buy this and get
your primary switch leave your standard
switch at home as your secondary one
because it's probably always connected
to Wi-Fi and you can have two switches
one of them being a very portable
version it also feels really good to
play well there you have it that's
Peters review of the switch light you
can check out the full written review on
gamespot comm you could also check out a
fact that we have to answer all your
questions about the switch light and we
also have a guide to transfer your
accounts between your switch and a
switch light if that's what's gonna get
it to so thank you for watching and take
the game spot for all our coverage
[Music]